well he also was an olympian and a
heisman trophy winner
uh our friend herschel walker is back
herschel your thoughts on the sports
aspects and i got a
question about politics i need to ask
you
well you know on the sports aspect of it
uh you know
it is sad and i think it'll continue to
go down unless we can remove that
political side out of sports
i think what we got to do is because
we're the greatest country in the world
and we do have the right to protest but
i think it's the wrong place wrong time
what we have to do as a people is we
have to decide that we have to elect the
right people into office
because if you get the right people in
office and hold people accountable
we wouldn't have these problems because
uh if you read the constitution
it talks about everything we want to
fight about today
and i think right now we have leaders in
washington
at this time that won't hold people
accountable so i think that's the
problems we're having but
this is the wrong place wrong time to do
it at the olympics because you're
representing the united states of
america
and to go to another uh country in the
olympics and put down
one of the greatest country in the world
where you cannot make the money that
you're making
in here in america you see in football
basketball
baseball and even in the uh and acting
world
you cannot make the money you're making
in this country that you can make
somewhere else
what do you think of the nfl adopting
social justice messaging in the
black national anthem is that a good or
bad idea
i think that's a bad idea i think it's a
bad idea because you know i think you'd
open up a can of worms
and the reason i say that is uh this is
the united states of america
and i said it one time and people may
get upset with me i said guys
we got to represent the united states of
america and if you don't like this
country
this country is so great that you don't
have to stay here this country is so
great you don't have to stay
but the thing is this is the united
states of america are we going to start
now having
everyone else national anthem come in
and we're going to have to uphold that
national anthem as well and forget about
the united states of america national
anthem and that's what i say
i think we got to get people that that
have become leaders that's not going to
stand for it
and there's no doubt you're going to you
got to treat people fair
you want to listen to them but at the
same time you got to let people know
that
this is the united states of america and
guys we want to
do the right thing when you talk about
john carlos and the people in the
olympics you got to remember this
at that time there was a separate
bathroom that that time
a lot of african-americans couldn't go
into a restaurant and eat
well they did protest and down with this
point here where we have an opportunity
to be treated fairly
but they're not upholding that by
holding people responsible for what
they're doing
all right let me ask you the important
question
um so i read people starting to attack
you a little bit
and i chuckled to myself because i've
known you
such a long time and seems to me that
there's a great fear that herschel
walker
is going to get in that senate race in
the state of georgia
where you are one of the most loved
figures uh
where are you on that decision
well you know as i told everyone i'm
going to do it on my timetable
and i think that's what making people
angry that's the reason that they may
have came out with something like that
but that's fine
because you know one thing about that
they don't know about herschel walker
stuff like that doesn't bother me
because if i'm going to run for office
i'm fighting for something much bigger
than herschel walker
so little articles like that ain't going
to scare me it ain't going to do
anything for me
i'm fighting for the people of georgia
i'm fighting for the united states of
america
and i'm fighting for this constitution
i'm fighting for law and order i want my
mom i want
any white mom i want any asian mom to be
able to go to a grocery store and feel
safe
and right now i don't think they can do
that
yeah this is scary times when you think
about it um
i have a lot of friends in georgia
they're waiting for that
that moment i understand you you're back
in georgia now
and um i don't know it seems to me like
you have georgia on your mind hershel
you know georgia's always been on my
mind that's what people don't realize
if they go back and look at anything
i've ever said
i said i'm a product of the state of
georgia anything that has happened in
georgia you will see herschel walker
that have showed up
and and now something is going on in
georgia right now i don't know what it
is
and if i'm the right man for the job
you'll see me step up and say i'm
running
and that's what i say i'm going to do
now but it'll be on my timetable no one
else's
all right herschel always great to have
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else